[Música]
y llegamos nuevamente a londres visa
seguimos con ustedes en este cubrimiento
especial que le estamos dando en directo
américa a lo que fue este discurso estas
palabras de renuncia del primer ministro
británico boris johnson tras esta
cascada de renuncias provocada por todos
los escándalos que han siempre
acompañado a este polémico primer
ministro luís y la pregunta del millón
que nadie sabía hasta ahora pero que se
baraja muchos muchos nombres después
hablemos de quién va a ser este sucesor
del primer ministro boris johnson que no
que boris johnson que nombres se manejan
hasta el momento los más fuertes que
puedan hacer el próximo primer ministro
de reino unido luís a
y raúl lo primero es que el sol ha
salido en esta jornada frenética en
estas 48 horas sin respiro que cambiaron
de una u otra manera la historia del
reino unido- como lo mencionas boris
johnson a finalmente ha dado un paso al
costado pero se mantendrá en el cargo
hasta finales de septiembre cuando se
realice la convención del partido
conservador en este país todos los
partidos en el otoño tienen sus
conferencias anuales parece que el
comité en 1922 que tiene mucho poder es
el encargado de sacar o no primeros
ministros ha acordado con boris johnson
que en la etapa final de esta carrera
para elegir su sucesor se dará cuando se
reúnan los miembros del partido cuando
queden dos bueno como te alcanzarás a
imaginar quienes quieren ser primeros
ministros ya ha empezado a levantar la
mano y a decir aquí estoy listo pero por
supuesto es un proceso que va a tomar
algunas semanas quienes crean que pueden
tener todas las cualidades y lo que
necesita este país para resolver esta
crisis institucional de autoridad esta
crisis es política pueden entonces
postularse bueno hablemos de algunos
nombres que sonarán familiares porque
hay unos integrantes del gabinete que ya
han dicho que están listos de una u otra
manera bueno tenemos a lis atrás que es
la secretaria de exteriores británica
que estaba en indonesia cumpliendo con
una agenda oficial y cuando se supo que
iba a renunciar su jefe el primer
ministro se sabe ha iniciado su regreso
a londres también el ministro de defensa
ben wallace que ha tenido un papel bien
protagónico en toda la invasión de rusia
a ucrania risas una quien hasta hace dos
días era el ministro de finanzas también
salia bid el secretario el ministro de
salud que en su discurso ayer en el
parlamento parece que lanzó su
candidatura dicen los expertos porque
dijo que está listo para poder asumir
retos mayores también algunos diputados
pero en orden son dagenham jeremy hunt
que también fue secretario de salud y
también corrió en la elección pasada
cuando boris johnson fue elegido y éste
la vulneran pero en las próximas semanas
y días de raúl estaremos escuchando
nuevos nombres de quien quienes quieren
entrar a esa competencia de reemplazar a
boris johnson y de a diferencia del 2019
cuando wes johnson fue elegido para
reemplazar atribuirse a may en este
momento no hay una candidatura tan
evidente tan clara así que tendremos que
ver cuáles son las propuestas que
presentan cada uno de estos candidatos
será un sorteo entonces el que tenga más
votos se pasará a la siguiente ronda y
así sucesivamente hasta que queden dos
candidatos los más fuertes entonces los
mismos del partido elegirán al sucesor
de boris johnson hablas del partido
conservador louis y cómo están las cosas
ahora internamente con este terremoto
político dentro de los tories
incluso en este discurso de renuncia a
boris johnson está tratando de demostrar
que tiene el control pero lo cierto es
que no lo tiene su futuro político no
está en sus manos sino en el de los
diputados de su partido el conservador
que ya algunos han hablado que no están
contentos que boris johnson se mantenga
por casi tres meses más en el cargo así
que se empiezan a barajar algunas
posibilidades la primera que ese proceso
de elección del primer ministro que
puede tardar unos meses se acelere que
incluso que haya un proceso de
eliminación de un candidato el que tenga
o menos votos porque esta será una
elección interna de los diputados
inicialmente en la primera etapa que la
eliminación se haga podría ser incluso
cada noche pero también el 'times'
reporta que incluso algunos diputados
han contemplado la posibilidad de que el
gabinete de johnson que se mantiene por
manera unánime determine que es el
momento de johnson de irse
independientemente de que él haya fijado
la fecha para el otoño y entonces podría
nombrarse un sucesor a do que podría ser
el vice primer ministro dominique rap
pero por supuesto estos son hasta el
momento posibilidades escenarios pero no
hay nada concreto lo que sí está sobre
la mesa es que boris johnson ha dado un
paso al costado y el cronograma para
elegir el nuevo sucesor en su sucesor se
conocerá en la próxima semana